these are the latest photos of the once
mysterious Pluto courtesy of NASA's new
Horizons probe the last time we heard
from New Horizons it was zooming away
from Pluto at about 30,000 miles per
hour
back in July the little space probe that
could made its closest approach to the
dwarf planet snapping photos and
furiously taking measurements knowing
that we Earthlings would be excited to
see what the icy Rock really looks like
NASA made sure that the probe sent a few
high-res photos back right away
scientists use those to make this super
cool animated flyover of its mountains
and Plains after nearly two months of
rest New Horizons is sending back images
again these are the first photos from
the probes intense data dump this is
what Pluto's surface would look like
from only 1,100 miles away it shows the
edge of Pluto's famous heart the big icy
blotch that scientists are calling
Sputnik Planum that area is relatively
young geologically but Pluto also has
much older dark cratered surfaces and
even some things that look like
windswept dunes and Charon
Pluto's biggest moon has some impressive
geology of its own you can expect lots
more where this came from but the entire
download will take a year